[THEME MUSIC PLAYING]
SALIL AMONKAR: Hi everybody.
How are you all doing?
It's after lunch.
(LAUGHS) Well, we
got a fantastic panel coming
up shortly to wake you all up.
And you guys heard today's
keynote, yesterday's keynotes,
a lot of good stuff
about AI and ML.
And we are going to
show you how AI and ML,
it can be applied
across the value chain.
And this is the theme--
"Bridge From Marketing
to Supply Chain."
I'm Salil Amonkar.
I am the COO of Pluto7.
And more importantly, I also
lead AI and ML Professional
Services Team.
And I have the good fortune
of having some of my customers
sitting along with me, will
join me shortly on this panel.
So without further ado,
being in the business
for such a long time--
and I've worked as both an
employee of a large corporation
and a management consultant.
And now I'm working as--
helping companies come up and
drive breakthrough innovation
using the latest technologies.
The key thing that
has stood out for me
is that typically,
a lot of enterprises
end up in having
focus on what I call
as a front end of the
enterprise value chain.
I define that more as
marketing the front end
of the whole business,
the customer-facing side
of a business in the value
chain, marketing sales.
And then you have the
operations and the supply chain,
which for our reference,
I'll define as the back end.
Typically, there's
been a lot of focus
on, how do you make the
profitability of the enterprise
or the customer experience
that an enterprise can
provide its customer seamless?
And we've seen
time and time again
that this has pretty much been
a challenge, even though there
have been advances
in technology.
Just to illustrate
that, I thought
this was a very apt
quote from Mark Anderson.
Pretty much, he captured
this very well saying
that, well, there were a lot
of technical breakthrough
technology possibilities.
Really the business--
there was a challenge
in how business could
achieve the results
despite those
technological innovations.
And that it was
not only the fact
that it was the business
who was willing to drive,
but develop technology
challenges that still stop
the business from
attaining those goals.
So, that falls very perfectly
with my opening statement,
which is essentially
the key to all this.
Driving the business
benefit starts
by making sure that you are
able to take the process--
the process there is
basically people, process,
and technology--
and have it work seamlessly
from the front to back.
It starts with the customer
and ends with the customer.
But for you guys as
enterprises, there's always
the front end or the
demand generation,
the marketing side
of the processes,
and then you have your
fulfillment processes,
which are mostly operational
that deals with supply chain.
So, the key thing is AI and
ML proposes some possibilities
to have a responsive back
end that can go hand-in-hand
with the front end.
And today's teams as you will
see in the panel discussion
is to give you some
ideas on how we
can see that
happening or, in fact,
what are the
challenges that still
exist that need to be
overcome in order to make
it even better?
And how does AI and ML fall into
the strategic aspect as well as
a tactical aspect
of enabling this?
So, a lot of
companies have already
started using AI on the
marketing side, to some extent,
even on the customer
relationship
management and sales.
AI has been seen to have given
very good results in this area.
The key is whether we can
follow that up and leverage
AI and ML also on the
operations and supply chain.
And that piece is
still evolving.
So just to encapsulate
this, pretty much
some of the key things
here are, you can come up
with a very good, efficient,
and targeted marketing leading
to competitive
advantage that can
be achieved through AI and ML.
It has been achieved through
traditional analytics
to some extent.
And you'll see, my
panelists talk about it.
And then the key here is
on the operations side
is doing exception
base demand planning.
Time and time again, when I
have provided solutions to large
customers or even
small customers,
even though they have
been good solutions--
and some of you are aware
of them like SAP, Oracle,
Value Gen Planning, SIPs,
advance supply chain planning--
every time we've implement it,
the customer has still come
back and asked, why can't I
do exception-based planning,
meaning, I need to only
know where the demand--
where do I have to pay
attention to my demand,
and where do I have to pay
attention to my supply?
So these are typical outcomes
where people have started
using AI and ML we have seen.
And again we'll go--
as the panelists talk about
it, hopefully this comes out.
It really helps, for example,
in coming up with the 360
view of the customer.
And that leads to increasing,
for example, your marketing
campaign efficiencies, and helps
drive revenue on the front end.
On the back end, it really
helps if you do this right
by coming up with a good
customer experience,
especially in
retail, where retail
has to be very
responsive, especially
with omni channel, et cetera.
And it allows you to do this
while maintaining productivity
and profitability.
And to really come
to this piece where
you can have the
true benefits, you
have to see some sort
of implementation
across the enterprise.
That's the goal.
So, how can ML drive
your transformation
of your business?
These are the three key elements
in that whole value chain.
And then, there's the marketing
ML, there's a demand ML,
and there's a supply ML.
I'm just simplifying this.
You heard it yesterday and
today, a lot of AI and ML
are making things simpler.
So to keep it simple
and easy, those
are the branding that
we have come up with.
And we'll expand into
this in the panel.
So without further
ado, I would like
to invite my panelists
up here to join me.
And we have a great set
off panelists today.
They are our customers.
And we will talk with them
on each of their experiences
that deal with the front end
and the back end of the process.
What are their thoughts?
What do they see as strategic
elements, the tactical elements
and their experiences in
trying to leverage AI and ML
in accomplishing
what I just said?
[APPLAUSE]
So before we start
the panel discussion,
I would like each one of
you to introduce yourself.
VIKRAM VERMA: Yeah, sure.
My name is Vikram.
I'm work as a senior manager
for the AI/ML Group in Cisco.
SUDHAKAR PARAKALA:
I am Sudhakar.
I run the enterprise
applications at Synaptics.
Just a brief overview
of the company,
we make anything
that you interact
with in electronic
device solutions
behind those interactions like
VV Touch our VV Fingerprint
Solution.
Or you might be ordering
pizza or something
on your Alexa device.
So we make solutions for
voice, fingerprint, and touch,
so it will be easy for
you to get that context
when I speak about how
we have utilized ML.
ADAM SPUNBERG: Hi,
I'm Adam Spunberg.
I lead the Global
Tech Exploration
part in supply for AB InBev.
So that's Anheuser-Busch for
those of you who don't know,
so beer production on a
global level across all
the continents.
DEEPAK MEHROTRA: Hi, I'm Deepak
Mehrotra, chief adventurer
at California Design Den.
We make something very simple.
Google wants you to be on cloud.
We want you to sleep on cloud.
We make bedding products.
And from a typical
design, manufacturing,
white label goods for retailers
in North America, a couple
of years is back, we
turn to the B2C side,
and now are like a retailer.
So we'll talk more.
SALIL AMONKAR: Thank you.
So I don't know how many of you
attended Adam's presentation
yesterday.
He went into more detail
on some of the things
around what they have done,
preventive maintenance.
He'll mention some of
it again here today.
But that was an
excellent presentation.
You can go back and review it.
As you know, those are still
available to view later on.
Thank you, Adam.
So let's start,
Vikram, with you.
And you may want to
keep the mic closer to--
VIKRAM VERMA: Sure.
SALIL AMONKAR: So, we
talked about AI and ML,
and I presented the front
end and the back end
of the processes.
And then we talked about
a lost opportunity.
And there's Mark
Anderson's quote,
which is talks a little
bit about the same thing.
What's your perspective?
VIKRAM VERMA: At the very high
level, I agree with his quote.
But at the same time, technology
is the enabler of the vision
that we have to
put in the front.
If we don't have the
vision, then technology
is not going to help
us in the long run.
There are a lot of examples
like Google, Amazon, all
these companies
where technology was
not there when they started it.
So if the vision was not
there, and if the willingness
of taking that vision to
reality was not there,
technology would not help us.
Now, there are a
lot of use cases
also where technology came
in, and as a human being,
when we learn somebody
else doing something,
we try to see how we can take
benefit of the same concept
and evolve to the next level.
So there are a lot of
examples in that as well.
So it is a philosophical
debate, but it depends
on how you want to take it.
I think ideas and a
willingness to take
those ideas to execution is
more important than technology.
SALIL AMONKAR: Very good.
Sudhakar, you want to
add anything to that.
SUDHAKAR PARAKALA: I agree.
So the problem of the
demand-supply matching
and time-to-market
were always there.
So we had to look
into solutions that
could help us to bridge the gap
as to optimize our inventory.
So recently for the
last couple of years,
we have realized
that there is ML,
and there are
technological improvements
wherein we could
leverage that technology
to bridge those gaps.
So now we think we are
at that point wherein
we could leverage
ML significantly
to achieve our goals.
SALIL AMONKAR:
Adam, any comments?
ADAM SPUNBERG: Sure.
I think one thing
interesting about that quote,
it focuses on the '90s as
if where we stand today,
we've solved all the problems
that prevented those businesses
from succeeding then.
But I think this is a universal
construct that will probably
continue to happen.
And people with
great vision today
may have ideas that
aren't possible now,
but might be more available
in 10 to 15 years.
So I'd go so far as to say
that I agree with his quote
and actually think it's
prophetic in some ways
about how technology works.
But as we advance, maybe
with such exponential growth,
that gap will diminish.
And we'll be closer and closer
between vision and technology.
DEEPAK MEHROTRA:
I think what Adam
said is so perfect, which is
exponential growth and bridging
the gap.
I don't think of anyone of us
in the room can imagine a world
where only large companies with
deep pockets are going to rule.
So the machines are here.
Whether they're going to
take over the world or not,
that's a philosophical
debate we can have.
But as a business
that is not big--
let's pick up a fight
with Amazon for now, which
happens to be our
number one channel,
but also happens to
be our competition.
The question is, what do we
do that we are in the race?
We are not behind it.
We can hopefully then compete.
And how would we scale?
How would we optimize?
How would we reduce wastages?
So all those questions
for any business around,
it's fairly simple.
I mean, it's not
going to be easy.
But if you're not in the
race, you'll be out of it.
So with that in
mind, things are only
going to get very interesting.
SALIL AMONKAR: So following that
Vikram your comments earlier,
how do you--
what is it about
that perspective
that you would like
to relate in the work
that, for example, you're
doing in your area or even
from your thought processes
as it relates to marketing,
and sales, and AI and ML?
VIKRAM VERMA: Yeah, absolutely.
There are a lot of scenarios
that we are currently
working on.
For example, when we started
this journey two years ago,
it was always about
customer success motion.
Once you bought
something, how do we
drive the value of
that product as soon as
possible to the customer?
And the key concept
over there was,
how can we understand
what you are looking
for from other software?
And where are the issues?
What are the challenges
that you are facing?
And how do we provide
that information
using the registered channels
or within the product as well?
Now we sell-- you
guys all now Cisco
has so many products
and so many softwares,
it's just not possible
humanly to do all of that.
So we had to apply them--
we had to use the machine.
To start with, we had to
go with business rules.
But later on, we went into
AI and all those things.
From a technology
point of view, I still
feel that there
is a lot of scope
in technology improvement.
For example, when we
look at AI, AI today
is a very specialized AI.
It can do certain things.
But when you look at generic
AI, it's still not there yet.
And I don't think the
technology is even there to.
But we cannot just think about
technology as a roadblock,
but think about what can
we do, what exists today?
And what is it that
we want to drive?
So when we started is journey,
it was more about can we
know our customers better, like
customer segmentation, customer
journey, how do they
use the product?
What are the features
that they use?
What they want to achieve?
What should we tell
them to use them more?
And through all
digital channels,
how we can communicate
that information back
to the customer, and then see
what works, what doesn't work?
So this things took
a lot of effort,
but this is where we
are heading towards.
And we are working tirelessly
to meet these goals.
SALIL AMONKAR: Very good.
You mentioned a very good
thing, you mentioned journey.
So Sudhakar, if I may ask
you, he gave the perspective
from the digital marketing.
What's your perspective
on this AI/ML journey
as it relates to supply
planning, supply operations?
SUDHAKAR PARAKALA: So
the space where Synaptics
is in, it's in a
high-tech world,
fast-moving products, and
cell phones, and tablets,
and laptops.
And the market that we are on
are the Alexas in the world,
so our time to market.
And we have to make sure that
our inventory is optimized.
At the same time, you don't
want to leave any money
on the table.
So our use case was, hey, if you
have to optimize the inventory,
then how do we go
about it, then we are--
absolutely we wanted
to focus on the demand.
So though our goal was inventing
optimization, so we thought,
why not start
looking into demand?
There's a lot of fluctuation.
There's a lot of inputs
coming from different parts
of the world.
And things are changing
as you can see,
I think the cell phone--
the life of a cell
phone is pretty small
when compared to some
of the other products.
So we had to look
into areas where
we could look into demand.
How would we try to look into
demand, predictive analytics
kind of thing.
So that's when we started.
Why not start looking into ML?
And so our journey has been,
we thought, let's start
looking into, if we can,
have ML predict our forecast
for the stable mature product.
So obviously, the goal was to
do the inventory optimization.
So, it's been a great journey.
We did get to a point wherein
for certain mature products,
we do have--
getting some confidence
that maybe we
can start leveraging ML to
start predicting our forecast,
as you mentioned before, so we
can focus on the exceptions.
So standard products,
everything that's mature, maybe
ML will drive the demand,
and the rest of it we
manage by exception.
So it's been a great
journey so far.
SALIL AMONKAR: Taking
from that, and I may--
Adam if I may ask you to add
to what Sudhakar just said.
But you did a phenomenal--
I mean your company
did a phenomenal work
in applying AI and ML working
with us to really come up--
I mean, do a change that
was-- it sound simple,
what you presented in
great detail yesterday.
What are your thoughts
that you would
like to share with this audience
in allowing the AI and ML
journey for innovation and
breakthrough business benefits?
Taking that as an example
so that they can understand,
for somebody who wants to
embark on that journey,
what are the things that
one to pay attention to?
ADAM SPUNBERG: Sure.
And I think AB InBev
stands out a little bit
from the other
companies on this panel
because the work
that we're doing
is not so much software-based.
We're a manufacturing
company more or less.
We're creating beer.
And so you probably
wonder where does
machine learning and artificial
intelligence play in there?
Well actually, in
very many places,
and I think we're just
scratching the surface.
So to go into the
specific example
where Pluto7 is
working with us is we
found that we could predict a
much more accurate filtration
process by using
artificial intelligence.
It's pretty remarkable how you
can study certain variables
by going through
the data, and having
enough data to do that,
and be able to predict
with much keener
accuracy when you
should replace a filter in
that fermentation process.
So it's a pretty
extraordinary thing.
And there's so much that goes
into making beer, for example,
that this is just one example
that we're starting with
to see how effective AI can be.
And we're very optimistic
about those results.
So I think spawning off from
that, any part of maintenance
could be predictive maintenance.
It could be something
in our packaging lines.
with maybe more along what
you are suggesting, predicting
inventory or customer demand.
There's really-- the
sky's the limit on this.
And I think for all
of you out there
that are involved in companies
who are considering this,
this really does seem
to be the most cutting
edge way to make that next
huge bump in advancement
toward the future.
SALIL AMONKAR: Thank you.
And Deepak, if I
may ask you, you
are a fast-growing retailer.
You have a lot of
business growth
and your scaling is
something that is always
at the top of your mind.
So with that in mind
and related to what
Adam and Sudhakar
just discussed,
what's your perspective?
DEEPAK MEHROTRA: Yeah, so for
us at California Design Den,
our focus has also
been trying to tie
the two ends, which is demand
forecasting and supply chain.
The whole question of
optimization of supply chain,
being like a startup again with
limited resources and growth
that's surpassing
and clearing anything
that we had ever forecasted,
it became very important
for us to ensure that the
decisions are near real time
and, again, managing
by exception.
Now imagine, I mean,
how many of you really
think that a bed sheet--
that's one of the key
products we make--
needs a retail shelf space on
the seventh floor at Macy's?
I mean, really, do we really
need a huge floor of selling
bed Sheets?
How many of you would go there
and be able to actually open
one of those bags and feel it?
Probably not.
So we see products like ours,
which are fairly commoditized,
completely being online.
And therefore, the
growth is phenomenal.
And we are competing
with our channels,
whether it's Walmart.com
or Amazon.com,
so it becomes very important for
us to be very nimble, be fast.
And in the journey towards--
from basically ensuring all
our data is in one place,
everything is flowing
into one place,
having a very distributed
supply chain, running from here
to factories in
India and China, we
have been taking on this journey
and seeing very good results.
Of course, those results
are still very basic,
whether it's inventory
reduction, or its speed
in making decisions for changing
what is in production line.
But how we are looking at ML and
then AI is that as we scale up,
and we face this
hyper competition,
we would be ready for whether
it's demand, forecasting,
supply chain planning,
price optimization, and what
have you.
SALIL AMONKAR: Thank you.
So Vikram, coming back
to you and marketing
on a similar theme.
Now that you've considered--
you've looked at--
I think you always
drove development
when it came to technology
because you have to do
that in digital marketing.
What are the considerations
especially around going
about your AI and
ML journey that you
want to point out, that would
be of interest to this audience?
VIKRAM VERMA: Is it
about strategical--
SALIL AMONKAR: Tactical.
Let's talk about both.
VIKRAM VERMA: So
one of the things
that I would say,
we have been using
a lot of prediction-based
modeling.
Earlier we used to
call it as forecasting
for late '90s in Cisco from
a supply chain point of view.
But this motion of
using the data science
not from forecasting, but from
prediction point is pretty new.
And from strategical
angle, there
are multiple things which
comes top of the mind.
There is a big hype
around AI and ML.
A lot of companies
today are investing
because they feel
it's magic, and it's
one silver bullet which will
solve all of their problems.
But I would just caution it.
It's not a magic--
it's not one silver bullet
which will solve your problem.
it's a big step forward.
And it requires a lot of hard
process change in the company
itself.
Your business objective
should be very, very clear.
A second thing is the way
you use it from a technology
and from data point of
view, data science and AI
can only work on
the data itself.
If you don't have the
data in a way that
could be used for
machine, it doesn't
mean that you need to have
Amazon or Google like exabytes
or petabytes kind of data.
But you should have
enough diversified data
that you could use it for
machine learning algorithm.
And the third thing is, as I
said, it's not a silver bullet.
It requires a lot of
work, sharing the data in.
And there should
be a willingness
to take that insight from the ML
and put them into the process.
Sometimes we get
a lot of insights,
but when we are trying to
drive that experience with
the customers, like
Cisco.com, for example,
when we want to say this
customer wants to only learn
about this, tell
him that message,
it goes into that channel,
oh, we know more--
should this be the
message, or no,
this page cannot be
customized for an example.
So sometimes it's in the
front end kind of work,
it becomes a difficult
when you the insight,
you know what the
customer wants.
But when you want to show
that message to customer,
your tools platform
doesn't support.
So there are a lot
of constraints.
I will just caution that
first from a strategical point
of view that AI is not which
can be implemented tomorrow.
It takes some time, especially
in a big company like Cisco.
The second thing from
technical point of view
is normal activities, like
what is it, till the time--
if you had a
business objects are
clear till the
time you get there,
how can you keep on adding
the value in the process?
Because everybody
thinks about AI,
they always think about either
optimization, whether it
you say cost or process.
Or you say, how can
I get the innovation
or competitive advantage?
And how can I use it to extend
our business to the next level?
But all of these things, when
you go to the technical level,
these things will take time.
And technically, you cannot
wait for a couple of years
to produce the results.
So you have to understand what
those business challenges are,
where the things could
immediately add the value.
So for example, we
were lucky enough
that we were part of
a sales organization.
And there are a lot
of companies which
has done a lot of
things for the sales
already, so we had to take those
learnings and see it just to
of our own culture.
So for example, customer churn
model, customer risk analysis,
lifecycle advantage,
product recommendation,
all those things what is the
right contract on this company?
What is the timing that
you should call that guy?
What is that
pre-scripted insight
when you talk to that customer?
All of these things
came in handy
to drive that
immediate value that we
had to show step-by-step before
we get to that bigger goal.
The second thing from a
customer success point of view
was all about, how do we provide
the right relevant message
for the customer and
change their experience?
So technically,
its more around how
can you keep on
adding the value,
but only when your strategic
objectives are very clear.
SALIL AMONKAR: Very
good points there.
I heard keeping focus on data
which we heard even during some
of the keynotes I heard.
Rajen mentioned that yesterday
and then also people always
vendors talk about AI and ML,
its all about data and then
understanding where
you want to go.
So Sudhakar similarly,
any insights
you want to talk about in the
first ML/AI proof of concept
that you did that you
would like to point out?
SUDHAKAR PARAKALA: I think it
has to be tightly integrated
with business planning.
So it's not just about
having data and trying
to come up with a magic formula
that its going to predict.
Especially for our use case,
it was demand plan, come up
with an accurate demand plan.
So you have to be
tightly integrated
with business planning as to
what are the elements that
go into a business plan.
One has to work with
the given amount of data
that is available to
put those things along
with the algorithms that
the ML can come up with.
So it's not just
throwing in data and then
its going to spit
out an end result,
and that's going to be
an accurate forecast.
That's not happening.
So the business plan--
anything that subjective,
objective, or anything
that you're getting from
the field data, when
one is creating that demand
plan and the business plan,
any element that goes
into the thought process,
we have to make sure
that the ML can--
we could try to incorporate
as much as you can,
only then maybe it
starts to understanding
that this not one
thing that you look
into when you enter a demand.
So if you're the person that's
responsible for next year,
maybe or whatever,
how many folks
are going to attend
this conference,
so it could not be
one factor or two
for you to accurately
predict that.
Similarly, we had
to get into that--
it has to be very
tightly integrated
with the overall business plan.
And it meant, like
you said, it's
not something that
comes out automatically,
so you have to then look
into what products can you
really apply that.
And that's going
to be more helpful.
So we're still in
a very early stage,
but we do see some
positive results.
Of course, some places
there are disappointments,
so we just have to continue
to tweak it, and fine tune
it, and get to a point.
So it's extremely
important to put
all the elements that are there
in our business plan into it.
It's been a great
journey as to--
we had some successes
and some, obviously,
we still have to learn.
SALIL AMONKAR: So Adam, I
heard from Deepak that it's not
magic, it requires work.
And Sudhakar mentioned
that hey, there has
to be focus and a plan behind.
In your example, one of
the things that I heard--
and I want to relate
it to your experience--
that was president
in the keynote
today by Rajen Sheth is
it's all about simple AI.
And I think in your
case, what we achieved,
or what you achieved was
something that at the end
became very simple.
So any thoughts around that?
ADAM SPUNBERG: Well,
one thing I think
is interesting about what
we're all trying to do here,
and I'll use our case with
AB InBev as an example,
is we're talking so much
about machine learning,
but what are we really
trying to relate to?
That's humans.
So it's an irony in a way
that we're using a machine
to better understand ourselves.
So until we enter a
world where maybe robots
are running everything and
then they'd be marketing
to themselves, who knows.
But for now, it's all
about that human aspect.
And that actually doesn't
just go for consumers.
That's also within the
organization itself.
And that's a battle
that I've had to fight.
And I don't say that
is a negative thing.
I think it's about
educating and getting
more and more people
aligned, especially
a big company like ours.
AB InBev has 250,000
employees or some such.
So you're not going to have
250,000 people on board
with AI from day one, and
certainly not key stakeholders
who aren't familiar with
the technologies yet
and haven't had a chance to
really understand the value
that it can bring.
So I think you say simple
AI, but what I would--
taking a play on those words,
I think a real key for us
if we want to lead this AI
revolution is to find a way
to simplify the message.
How can we show this value to
everybody, top up and down,
that they can see
what we can achieve?
And that it's not a threat.
If anything, it's
an enhancement.
SALIL AMONKAR: Thank you.
Deepak, any comments?
DEEPAK MEHROTRA: I think as
far as ML and AI is concerned,
it's more like a journey.
So as you said, it's
not a magic bullet.
And the biggest advantage that
we feel at California Design
Den, trying to ensure that
we set the vision that this
is what is going to drive
competitive advantage, then
product differentiation may not
be a differentiating factor.
This kind of drives
us as a company
to set everything in place.
So it's not that
we have to set up
some new system that's only
going to do ML-based demand
forecasting.
So whether it is basic
analytics to advance analytics
or what have you,
it's like a journey.
But once you have a vision that
this is where you need to be,
and many of those visions
are still visionary visions,
this does bring in a
lot of efficiencies.
It becomes a rallying point
between the key stakeholders.
There's an added
advantage where you'll
have to relook at
all your processes
and what have you
because as Adam said,
not everyone gets
on board right away.
So you internally
debate, figure out
what do you do, break
all molds, make new ones.
So we see AI/ML
not just in what we
expect it to produce
after a few years,
but also as a driving force
towards being on your feet
and just pushing hard,
and being in the front.
SALIL AMONKAR:
Thank you, Deepak.
So now between Vikram,
you and Sudhakar,
your represent the
high tech industry.
I would like to hear
Vikram first you
and then Sudhakar following
him, your thoughts on--
now that you have
embarked on this AI and ML
and started using it,
at least beginning
to understand how to use it
in your respective spaces,
I would like--
I think you articulated,
although in some places,
that it's a journey, what do
you see in the high tech space?
Where do you see AI
being leveraged more?
And where do you want
to give this audience--
OK, here you might be
tempted to go into AI,
but you may want to go with
a little bit of caution.
Because I think one of
the things that what
I'm trying to understand
is in your experience
that I'm sure what the audience
would like to understand
is, as you are going
through these journeys,
there are learnings.
OK, AI, everybody wants to
get into the AI/ML bandwagon.
But not every use case may
be meant for AI and ML.
So any perspective taking
that into consideration?
VIKRAM VERMA: Yes.
When we talk about
AI or ML, there
are always risks and
benefits to that as well.
When we talk about any
model or any recommendation,
there is always a
percentage of accuracy.
And one of the things
that I was talking earlier
was when we look
at the MLs today,
these are specialized
models, specialized models
learning from the data
about previous behavior.
With these set of
behaviors, this
was the outcome
that [INAUDIBLE]..
And that drives your
prediction about what shall
you do tomorrow because
there's the same pattern, which
will repeat the same
thing, assuming that.
So when we put the models in, we
get one thing is we cannot just
blindly trust the model.
There has to be some way of
understanding what those models
or outputs are talking about.
Put the human intelligence
around it, and then
say, does this case
even make sense or not?
So when we were
working on a project,
customer segmentation-- which we
are still working on to evolve
it to the next level--
we realized that we were able to
divide our customers in around,
for that one particular product,
the customer set into like 16
different segments.
But when we looked at with
the business owners trying
to understand what does
it really represent,
and how shall we drive
that experience of each
of the segments, what each
of the set of customers, half
of them did not even make sense
to them because it was more
around, you know
what, this seems
pretty much similar to that.
Their messaging
will be different.
So why don't we
merge it together?
This one does not even make
sense because these things is
like, if everyone is
using perfectly, then
what will we do with them?
So when we look at the
machine, these kind of risk,
we cannot blindly
trust the machine yet.
It's a specialized
AI, which does
specialized things even better
than human in certain aspect.
But human supervision in putting
that through the motion is
still very much required,
that intuition of looking--
let's say these patterns
meant customers will order,
but those patterns does not mean
much in today's environment.
How can we understand from it?
How can we apply
our human knowledge?
And how can we keep
it always tuned
in to the realistic business
scenario becomes the most
important work in the AI?
It's not just getting the
data, getting meaningful data,
deriving the insight, and
putting the insight to work,
but it's all about
taking that model,
making an intelligent
decision around it,
and then putting
it to work, which
makes it a [INAUDIBLE] cycle.
So human interaction is very
important, in my opinion,
to take this AI to the market.
Maybe when the technology
was in certain time,
and when we have
general purpose AI,
then it's a different story.
But for now, it's
a specialized AI.
And MLs are specialized
models based on the data.
It should not be taken
on the face value.
There are certain use
cases, like vision detection
and all those things where
AI has already improved
beyond human capability.
But when we talk about business
sense or what makes sense
and what does not, I think
putting blind trust in that
and taking the action on
that without supervision can
produce more--
can produce more
risk than advantages
in certain scenarios.
SALIL AMONKAR: OK, thank you.
I think the summary
of what you said
is any AI solution requires
technology and domain
and business expertise.
And the second
thing is there are
models that can be
leveraged as is,
meaning what they call
the pre-built models,
vision API you talked about.
But there are certain
situations and some
of the most of the
business situations
where you have to
have a custom model.
Thank you.
Sudhakar, any perspective from--
SUDHAKAR PARAKALA: So,
we took a little bit
of a simplistic
approach, wherein
obviously, like Adam
mentioned, first thing was ML
is going to predict my demand?
No way.
So can ML really predict
what kind of dinner
you are going to have?
No way.
So obviously there was
that kind of a thinking
within the company.
Then we took a much more
simplistic approach as to OK,
in all the different product
lines or different customer
segments, let's pick
something that where
you think this could be a little
bit of more predictability
within the human thinking.
So within your own
thinking, there
could be certain things
that you are more
consistent in your thinking.
There could be
some where you are
trying to gather additional
data to digest and come up
with a solution or an answer.
So then we have to dig through
those questions as to OK,
what are the areas
where you could
be more consistent,
the customer could
be more consistent, the market
could be more consistent,
so we can drive our inventory
optimization by understanding
how the demand is
being generated,
so we picked up more of those
mature products our markets.
So obviously, the acceptance
has to come into picture
that hey, what the
machine is predicting
is pretty much close to
what can I rely on it?
So you have to take
the use case wherein
one starts getting confidence
and so obviously, you
want to pick up the products
and the markets that are
a little bit more consistent.
Obviously the value is
in the unpredictability
where it can predict, but
you can't start with that.
So we took a
simplistic approach.
Let's take baby steps.
So we are at that stage where
we came up with the first use
case, now we'll take
it to the next level.
Can I really apply it to the
NPI, new product introduction?
We don't know.
I think that's to be seen.
SALIL AMONKAR: Thank you.
I think the summary there is
crawl, walk, and then run.
Adam, I think from an
AB InBev prospective,
you presented a very great
vision in your discussion
yesterday.
I think as a representative of
the manufacturing industry--
because I look at AB InBev as
one of the largest breweries,
and you can say it's
representing the manufacturing
industry, what would
be your takeaway
be from that perspective
around usage of AI and ML?
ADAM SPUNBERG: Sure.
And I do have to
say, you keep saying
that we did this
great presentation,
but honestly give
yourself some credit.
You know, Pluto7 is the
company that really did
the machine learning and AI.
We just accepted it and
put it into our system.
So all credit to you guys.
But I'd say this, you have to
find use cases that make sense.
And I think this is
very in line with what
was being said before,
is that the fact is
AI is not going to be the right
solution for a lot of things.
And I think there will
be more and more use
cases as technology advances
and foundational layers
of technology.
So say in our breweries,
the more advanced
our data collection is, for
example, the more opportunities
will emerge where we can
do things with that data.
But it's essential
that you really
do have the right situations.
And I think that's where someone
could run after this a little
irresponsibly and just get so
excited about the AI/machine
learning idea that, oh,
we can do ML everywhere.
And that's really not true.
If you were going to go
swimming in a children's pool,
you wouldn't say, let's go
buy scuba gear to do that.
There's certain things-- you
have to find the right setting.
And I think that's a
combination of, in our case,
working together with
experts who really
do know the right situation.
In the case of Pluto7 with us,
we actually held a hackathon
where we explored
a number of areas
where we thought AI
could be valuable.
And we looked to them to come
up with a model that worked.
And from those
different options,
it became apparent that we
had found something here.
So I think to pursue something
in this space for all of you,
I would just make sure that
it's a prudent decision.
Definitely I'm not trying to
stop anybody's excitement.
Be as passionate as
possible, but save yourself
the trouble of overdoing it
for the wrong situations.
SALIL AMONKAR: Thank you Adam.
And then before we open it
up to the audience, Deepak,
final thoughts from
you as a representative
of the retail industry and
a high growth one at that.
DEEPAK MEHROTRA: I wouldn't go
as far as representing retail,
that Mr. Bezos
would be better off.
But I'm thinking like ML/AI
is like a little baby.
So you start putting
in data, you still
have to feed and
change the diapers.
And that's where
we are right now.
We are hoping that
in a few years,
this baby is going to grow up.
And she's going to run.
And she's going to do pole
vault, which I never did.
And she's going to win Olympic
medals, which I couldn't even
dream of.
So this is pretty much how
we are looking at ML and AI.
So it's with us,
we have to pick--
with this, we are driven to
ensure that we think future,
we set up systems, data
flow, rethink processes.
And then, the planning in a
box that we did with Pluto7, we
were able to see some good
results as far as demand
forecast and supply chain
optimizing is concerned.
So we press a button,
we see what's going on,
we quickly change what's
in the supply chain.
I mean, it's still basic.
There is a speed now.
So 500, 1,000, 2,000 SKUs
that we have to manage.
We are able to do it
quick and really fast.
Now, when will this baby grow
up and just take all the charge?
Well, we'll see when.
SALIL AMONKAR:
Thank you, Deepak.
I think with that, I'd like to
open this up to the audience.
We have about five minutes left.
AUDIENCE: Is there
any packages that--
package applications
out there that can help
jumpstart your application?
SUDHAKAR PARAKALA: It's
more for you, I guess.
We didn't use any packaged--
SALIL AMONKAR: OK, I think
I'll leave it to Deepak.
Yes, Deepak, the
question is, is there
any packaged
application out there
that can help jumpstart
their business?
DEEPAK MEHROTRA: Well, it'll
sound like unsponsored ad,
but we used planning in a box
that Pluto7 has, which uses,
of course, Google
Cloud and ML and AI,
things within the
Google ecosystem.
That did help us a lot
as far as our inventory
controls are concerned.
So with much very fast demand,
very decent demand forecasting,
and a quick connection
to supply chain,
we were able to see very
visible inventory reductions.
AUDIENCE: And then help move
fast movers to slow movers?
DEEPAK MEHROTRA: Can you
repeat your question, please?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] fast
movers and slow movers.
DEEPAK MEHROTRA: Right.
I think more with
the fast movers.
Because again, we as a
company, our slow movers
are really slow.
So one of the disadvantages,
as we were talking earlier,
you need to have data to
run some of these models
and see real results.
So our slow movers are
really slow movers.
We didn't expect actually
some of the results
to be benefiting the slow-moving
SKUs and what have you.
So we kept our safety
levels in that case
and worried more about
what was really selling
and where we had growth.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
DEEPAK MEHROTRA: Sure.
SALIL AMONKAR: Any
other question?
Great.
If not, I think
that's pretty much it.
Feel free to drop by
our booth at Pluto7.
I have put it up there.
We can show you more demos on
what's possible with AI and ML.
Thank you very much.
[THEME MUSIC PLAYING]